I'm Daniel Dwyer right here in the
GameSpot stage I'm delighted to be
joined by Josh Brousseau associate
producer with EA Sports UFC how you
could do him oh I'm doing great and I'm
glad to be here yeah this is a game that
a blonde people waiting to come out
because it is a difficult game to
convert into a sport to convert it into
a video game and you guys have a lot of
pedigree but what you worked on with
Fight Night Champion and I think a lot
of people are sort of cautiously
optimistic that you guys might have
actually nailed it well you know MMA is
a complex nuanced sport so it's hard to
mimic that in a game without sort of
being true to the sport so you know we
do a lot in terms of modes and tutorial
tutorial ization we have a specific game
mode called challenges where players can
go and practice very specific portions
of the game so you know if my Brazilian
Jujitsu is not very good I can go there
and practice just that if I want to work
on my takedown defense I can go and do
that and so you know really just trying
to bring players through the experience
promotes a great sort of opportunity to
do that as well we need to get tossed
into fight now it's a little bit
overwhelming but we're doing we're doing
our best to sort of you know gradually
teach players how to you know do the BJJ
the grappling clinching excellent
alright let's look at them what's
happening here start on the screens here
yeah I want to talk over Bruce Buffer
but we got Anna D Pettis forces UFC
legend Bruce Lee Bruce Lee I mean so
Bruce Lee comes in for weight classes
this is the lightweight weight class
right now what you're seeing right now
is one of our fighter intros Anthony
Pettis they're sort of stalking around
the Octagon and it's interesting enough
we did 3d head scans and for all the you
see fighters and getting bruce lee so we
actually had a head cast send down oh
wow have you got the tattoos all done as
well what was it like with Conor
McGregor got that stuff done like after
you guys count him I'm guessing you know
I think it was a real real sort of way
to rush to sort of take care of that I'm
not surprised get him to send some
haich-d air it's a great you though it
is yeah it's pretty good I like the
detail you got Mario Yamasaki doing a
little hard thing as well you guys seem
to have like if if nothing else at this
stage I've absolutely nailed the
presentation it's almost exact same as
watching a paper yeah you know we did a
lot in terms of one in
give personality to the characters and
make them feel like their true life
counterparts so you know dos Santos
Winkies introduced in the Octagon he'll
walk to the middle and you know arm
throw down Jesus people rush to the
Octagon I'm just doing as much as we can
to give some personality and flavor
I guess I'm syllabic kind of creeps away
John John Jones start off in as you
notice dance and so let's talk about the
moment-to-moment action here especially
for folks who might not be familiar with
the sport or the previous games
so essentially what what are you doing
as controlling one player what are you
thinking about in this situation I'm
sorry what are you thinking about when
you're actually playing this game in
terms of like one of the one of the core
components of the game is you know
stamina management it's all about
controlling your exertion making sure
that you're not you know going on the
offensive too much it's you gotta have
to mix up both defense and offense so
it's both managing your stamina watching
what the other players doing maybe
trying to exploit you need Falls in
their game so you know if a guy's not
taking you down maybe his ground games
not very good it's time to go down there
the UFC is a sport MMA is a sport that
often invites patience like it's perhaps
not a badge trying to knock somebody out
immediately
absolutely video games are perhaps not
normally when we're playing them we
don't play it that way and how do you
guys manage that trying to keep the pace
realistic without you know whatever
whatever making the game tedious or
forcing people to be patient um you know
I think are a real time exertion system
that we have just a good job of you know
forcing players to sort of pace
themselves again you know as you as you
play through career mode you'll be
you'll
learn how to sort of control your Sam to
manage it managed to sort of the pace
that you're going at on this definitely
a game that you can get into and you
know just sort of go crazy but a more
rewarding to sort of take it slow sort
of take your time I mean MMA is a game
of chess yeah and you were trying to
mimic that here
awesome I saw that so it looks like
Anthony Pettis just got a cut yeah yeah
he's got a bit of a mascara going on
there
how how brutal you guys get with the
like the actual skin modeling and stuff
and muscles is incredible and realistic
howdy-ho hetp you guys get with with in
terms of like the facial scarring and
stuff like that yeah I see you guys on a
breaks I mean our damage system our
damage system is not just for the head
you know as you take the body swelling
and redness and the more damage that you
take the worse that wall so if I check
in Anderson Silva kick is he gonna break
his leg in half though unfortunately no
I mean that is something that happened
suddenly something that we're looking
into but it but is it something you want
it like that's the sort of things like
yeah I mean I have stuff like nobody
watches a Rousey fight to watch somebody
break their so our philosophy is if it
happens in the Octagon should happen in
the okay and so we're striving to make
sure that we deliver on that cool so you
guys are gonna launch a UFC is it is a
sport and an event that continues around
the clock changes a lot in terms of like
belt changes and in terms of like people
who are taking time off for instance did
GSP and like this is something a lot of
EA games do were like FIFA and NHL is
there something that you guys are gonna
take it to in terms of fighters taking
time off I don't think that we would
exclude anyone from the roster and based
on that but certainly you know we'll be
offering free roster updates to sort of
flesh out the roster and include any
holes in the she's got Arianny as well I
believe so yeah everything unfortunately
was not there did you scan Rogen and
Goldberg as well
definitely and so yeah in terms of the
comments or the commentary is it the
a-class commentators do you have any of
the guys who do the the non-main right
now
Joe and Mike but I mean again that was
something that I think ken Florian only
started commentating you know maybe
again you know we made this game in a
very short amount of time in about two
years so definitely in the future that's
something that we would consider adding
cool and I want to talk to you a little
bit about the ground game and one of the
most difficult things even about
watching UFC when you first get into it
is trying to understand where openings
are and where opportunities are that's
difficult as a spectator so how do you
try and educate because essentially your
job is to not only educate a player
about how to play this video game but
also what the rules are UFC are and
where the opportunities are how well how
much of a challenge is that for you guys
oh well you know I think it's just we
looked at obviously what past titles
have done and trying to improve on that
I mean the ground game all of the sort
of the positional changes are very
intuitive they're all on the right stick
and it's all sort of gesture based
movements and of course I can both
attack and defend those yeah so I mean
it's something that players are gonna
have to learn but there's there's
definitely gonna be a rewarding and full
and do you guys have an octagon in the
studio have any you guys rolled there's
about 20 of us that they're all our
entire gameplay team and some of them
are actually doing competitions now oh
really
yeah so you guys were fighting a
champion devs as well that's correct
many of us were yeah yeah and that was
perhaps I personally I think that's the
best fight night game and there and I
loved all those games awesome one of the
things I loved about it a large that I
see here is in terms of the animation
and the way in which the the fighters
react to getting hit but one of the
premium things I love about finite
diamond was all you guys did with the
campaign with that single player is
there any of that being crossed over
into EA Sports UFC or was that just too
much of a challenge to do in the first
game I mean that was a huge undertaking
that we don't find a champion I'm
definitely not the first person to you
know ask her or say that you know that's
something that we should continue to try
and do yeah in terms of in terms of you
see we really wanted to focus on the
gameplay for our career mode though it's
for the first time in any you see gamer
The Ultimate Fighter so I really start
off in the top house and you know other
contestants for an opportunity to be on
it's not a custom character do you make
yourself absolutely yeah cool could you
do male and female you cannot do female
okay um but yeah you can create yourself
and you download your game face and
actually put yourself in but you guys
have got female fighters right Ronda
Rousey's in here me chase the
bantamweight women's boxing yeah no
tapes Rousey awesome who else do you
have who do you not have because at this
stage it looks like you like if you've
got if you've got them McGregor which by
the way thanks for that really
appreciate it
as an Irishman and just run through some
of the I'm guessing you got every single
way I mean the you see roster and of
itself is is massive yeah so obviously
there's some fighters that sort of got
left off the table but like I said
before we're working on a free roster
updates and we're making sure that you
know we're focusing on the you know up
and comers and the current champions do
you have any classic fighters at all I'm
sorry you have any classic fighters or
you yeah we have like Chuck Liddell
Royce Gracie Rich Franklin so you know
there's a mix of Legends champions up
and comers cool another really cool
thing about finite champion was the the
store where you could share out the
fighters that you had created and one of
the funniest things I think last year I
went to play it and people have made
everything from from golem to Gandhi to
Michael Jackson and all that sort of
stuff yeah are you guys do you guys have
that sort of fighter sharing stuff in
you know on fine a that was you know the
the whole created fighter system was
very important to that game because you
know we had a licensed fighters in
individually you know it was important
for us to you know allow players to sort
of flesh out that that but in in you see
there's no fighter share but players can
create their guy they can't fight with
them online
cool at that single player and element
the story you were talking about and how
long is that it's not just generally a
more of an introduction to the mechanics
rather than something to people that
we've been playing a lot of I mean the
career mode is going to change depending
on how
you play so there's a concept of both
popularity and longevity
so longevity determines you know how how
long can I fight and popularity
determines you know how popular
obviously you know that it's basically
sort of a tug of war between those two
mechanics you know if I'm if I go out
there and I stand and brawl I'm gonna be
really exciting to watch yeah but my
career's not gonna last very long so
it's important to sort of you know
manage both your popularity how and how
exciting it is for me in terms of them
like the variability within fights we're
watching a three red fight here do you
have five five round fights as well for
peloton yeah we have three round fights
five round fights both five-round fight
championship and non championship
matches so I just want to take a moment
to talk with yeah go for it absolutely
this is the new submission game that
that we have and it's what we're doing
it's a staged approach here so game is
good it's good it's good too and you can
see sort of the redness on the ribs
there yeah
the submission system is sort of a
staged approach so if I do the work to
get into a full mount
then the number of stages I have to go
through GM slap that submission on and
complete it is gonna be zero I love
t-shirts on and for the for the lift as
well this is interesting
interesting note about the t-shirts for
Bruce Lee is that that's actually
authentic dussander prizes fight Oh
excellent you can buy the in-store right
now and Mario puts up pedis his hand and
we're done yeah there you go
I'm guessing there's no Rogen interviews
after every single five if not yet you
guys seem to have bit off a lot and
looks like you chewed on a pretty good
EA Sports UFC is looking pretty tight I
know that the demo came out last week
demos oh no and games on Tuesday when
it's on Tuesday don't in dust it all
right once yeah once a a3 is done I'm
outta here to play some jazz Michelle
absolute pleasure to talk to you surfing
so yeah yeah best of luck with EA Sports
UFC and and I'm continuing I hope it's a
franchise that continues on and we get
to see better iterations off as we go
forward